And we know this has created a lot of hardship for so many.
This is trash.
It's crippling a sector of our economy,
that's already limping.
To persecute us
as an industry based on five or six weeks
of spiking cases that probably have very little to do
with outdoor dining is just crazy.
On November 22nd,
Los Angeles became the only county in America
to ban outdoor dining this winter
for a minimum three weeks.
This order could put out of business
many California restaurants that were barely hanging on.
Some of which recently invested in retrofitting
for exclusively outdoor dining.
The worst part, according to critics
is that the public health agency issuing the order
has provided no concrete evidence that outdoor dining is a significant source of COVID spread.
I personally feel like we're being punished.
Kat Turner is a chef and partner at Highly Likely cafe
in the West Adams neighborhood of Los Angeles.
The data to support that
COVID is being spread through outdoor dining,
I think it's extremely flimsy.
I just don't understand the agenda that's being pushed.
They've shut us without saying, hey, here's a solution,
this is how we're gonna help businesses,
this is how we're gonna help you get through this period,
because they knew it was coming,
but where's the planning?
Where's the foresight?
David Combes is the CEO of Botanical Group
which owns two restaurants in West Hollywood
including EP and LP,
which shifted all of its business to outdoor rooftop dining.
We've spent a considerable amount of money,
our additional investments
being in the hundreds of thousands of dollars
from additional staffing required,
security required to manage patrons
and make sure there's distancing applied barriers
and sanitizers.
Health Department--they visit us to check for compliance.
I'm happy to say that we've sailed through
with flying colors,
certainly made our life challenging
and profitability an impossibility.
LA county's Department of Public Health
issued the order the weekend before Thanksgiving.
Pointing to a 108% increase in case numbers
and rising hospitalizations
as rationale for the renewed restrictions.
Gathering with people you do not live with
can increase the chances of getting or spreading COVID19.
LA Public Health Director.
Barbara Ferrer held an online press conference
on November 23rd to discuss the order
and estimates from the county's contact tracing
that 10 to 15% of COVID transmissions are linked
to dining experiences.
Though she hasn't clarified,
how many of those transmissions
were attributed to outdoor dining at restaurants
and declined to provide the underlying data
when pressed by reporters.
Has there been a noted outbreak
that has come from people dining outside?
People are eating and drinking
and they're not wearing their face coverings
for the vast majority of time that they're there.
When they're gathered with people
who are not in their household,
there just ends up being
a significant amount of risk associated.
I think the question, and I don't know that you answered it,
is she wanted to know a number
of outbreaks as a result of restaurants--
I don't have those numbers in front of me
but I will be happy to
work with our communications team
and we'll get those numbers.
The Health Department didn't respond to Reason's follow up requests for those numbers,
and the county's online data portal
identifies only 16 restaurants as outbreak sites.
Most of them fast food restaurants involving only employees
not outdoor diners.
And restaurants don't make the county's top five list of COVID exposure sites.
The counties also found
that the vast majority of restaurants
do comply with its health orders
and that cases fell through the summer,
even as outdoor dining was allowed.
Given that you haven't identified an actual
source of an outbreak being in outdoor dining
how do you rationalize the closure
and how do you expect
to measure whether it actually is accomplishing
what you're hoping to accomplish?
We know that places where people are gathering
without wearing their face coverings
are places where transmission is easiest and most likely.
But we will, as always, watch our data.
The counties had eight months to get their shit together
in relation to contact, tracing, and also testing.
So it feels like we are being disadvantaged
by a lack of process from the LA County.
And now, for political optics,
it's, the requirement for them to do something is
well the first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna shut down restaurants and bars.
I think it's stupid.
I think people are still gonna wanna get together,
and now they're gonna do it inside
at other people's homes,
instead of meeting outside at a restaurant to have dinner.
And now that it's colder outside
they're not gonna wanna sit in the backyard.
They're gonna sit in the living room.
The Los Angeles County Board of supervisors
voted three to two to uphold the Health Department's order.
One restaurant owner has already filed suit against the County.
Turner says she worries about the unintended consequences
of an indefinite shutdown of one of the only relatively
safe places that people in Los Angeles can gather.
With the very fabric of our mental health
as a community kind of hanging in the wires,
and the financial stability of us as a business
and the livelihood,
the literal survival of my team gets completely
irresponsible to shut down outdoor dining.
Like what we have here is good for the community
and it's good for the economy
and it's good for our staff
and we're doing it safely.
Like this is not dangerous.